good morning hello yes hi I'm Mark
Rendell and welcome to the history of
programming part one which somebody
obviously thought was going to be more
popular than it is so this is this is
that's not a very impressive slide
opening slide for a talk of this
magnitude so here's a better one
there we go the history of red so this
is actually the second part because
obviously the first part was the history
of programming part zero bickers
programming and so this goes from 2018
to 2046 which will make sense by the end
of the talk ish
so just I've never done the the original
history of programming part zero talk
south of Islington actually so let's
just do a quick recap of the history of
programming from the beginning of time
up until now so the first programmable
thing that is recorded in human history
was invented by this guy in 60 ad this
is hero of Alexandria except when you
look into it a bit more his name's
actually Heron of Alexandria so you can
sort of see why he dropped to the N and
he invented automaton device with little
people on it that could be programmed
with pieces of string attached to
pulleys and wheels and by arranging the
strings in different ways you could make
the little people do different dances
which was sort of technically
programming and then things moved very
very quickly
and it was only eighteen hundred short
years thanks to the Catholic Church and
the endowment and the Middle Ages and
cheers guys ya know we'd be in space by
now and then in the in the night
18th century this guy came along this is
Charles Babbage and Charles Babbage
invented the calculating engine and the
difference engine he actually invented
two of these things and one of the
things I love about Charles Babbage is
he had this idea for this computer and
he went to the UK Parliament and he said
give me a million pounds and they went
what cuz you know in those days a
million pounds was a lot of money not
like now with brexit where it's cool and
they said all right you can have a
million pounds to go away and build this
thing and so he started building it and
machining the parts and everything else
and he got halfway through and then he
had a better idea and he went back to
the UK bother I know you've made two
million pounds because I've had a better
idea and I just think it's great the
computer design and development started
as it meant to go on but he never
actually built either of these machines
this is one that was built much much
later this is in the Science Museum in
London London back home and it works
that's the amazing thing this this
design that he had when they built it
they went bloody hell it actually works
and again think where we could be if
they'd if he'd finished it the first
time around but he published the specs
and a guy wrote biography of Charles
Babbage and he wrote it in Italian
because he was Italian I guess and this
lady decided she was going to translate
that into English and this is Ada
Lovelace and so she translated the book
in from Italian into English and she
thought while I'm at it I'll write an
example program for this thing so she
wrote the code and algorithm to
calculate Bernoulli numbers I've no idea
what those are it sounds awfully clever
and so she is effectively the world's
first computer programmer and when they
built this they got her program and they
fed it into the machine and it did it
calculate it Bernoulli num
so not only did she write the first
program she wrote the first program with
no automated testing and it worked first
time which is pretty awesome do you ever
have that thing where you write some
codes and it's like you have to write
five thousand lines of code before you
can test that any of its worked and then
you hit f5 and it works and you go no no
I've missed something here somewhere but
unsaddle e for ada she wasn't around but
happily for aider she did get a language
named after her has anyone ever
programmed in ada
no sadly for ADA it is one of the worst
programming languages in exit it's a
real-time programming language it's
designed for missile guidance and
defense systems and stuff like that it's
very scary and so then we had another
kind of 50 years of nothing really
happening until the Second World War
when we had to invent computers in a
hurry to defeat the Nazis and so Alan
Turing and Tommy flowers and those guys
built computers and then in the 1950s
people went oh you know what these could
be really useful for for calculating
things like missile trajectories and so
forth and for a long time computers were
just for war and you programmed them
might sort of putting bits of bits
literally bits in you do this and then
push a button and those bits would go in
and then do the next byte and that byte
would go in and eventually people
started going you know what this is a
really [ __ ] way to write software and so
they started inventing programming
languages and one of the first kind of
mainline programming languages was
Fortran and this is hello world in
Fortran and Fortran is still in use
today
mathematical people use it it's one of
the few languages that actually compiles
the SSE instructions for Intel
processors so that's hello world in
Fortran and then other languages started
popping up Algol 58 which was the very
very first thing that would eventually
become C and this is hello world in
Algol 58 he couldn't do it
because Algol 58 did not have IO
so hello Haskell programmers yeah this
is you Algol 60 hello world and Algol 60
looks very much like it does in the knr
book hands up who learned see from the
K&R book oh wow
old people hello I'm not alone or you
get Millennials going who RK on our hack
and then we had sort of the more the
more formal languages came along this is
hello world in IBM COBOL that is the
minimum amount of code you have to write
an IBM COBOL to get hello well displayed
on the screen COBOL was about half that
size but IBM COBOL IBM basically started
as they went to go on there's another
programming language called APL which
stands for a programming language
because by the time he'd invented it
he'd run out of imagination and so when
he came to give it a name is just APL
HelloWorld in APL is just quote
HelloWorld close quotes because if
there's no instruction it just assumes
you want me to write that to the
standard output which you think is very
sensible you think APL what a sensible
programming language and then you see
Conway's Game of Life in APL yeah he
decided you know this whole thing did
anyone go to Jeff's talk about how to
make money from open-source so Kevin
Kenneth Iverson who invented APL he
obviously thought I'm going to
open-source the programming language and
then I'm gonna cash in on selling the
keyboards because you did you had to buy
a special keyboard to program an APL and
you had to buy that keyboard so you
could program an APL so that you could
pass Kenneth Iverson's course at
university so yeah there's lots of
interesting programming languages I
don't know if you guys had this here did
you get this the ZX Spectrum yeah this
was like the home computer in the UK
when I was nine years old so there you
go that dates me and this this actually
taught programming
really well because each of these keys
has a keyword written on it
so you would type we've press P and it
would write print for you and so it was
really really nice and I learned to
program on a spectrum and you could make
fairly interesting games using spectrum
basic one of the things it wasn't great
at was graphics and the main way you did
graphics when you're an amateur
programmer sort of learning out of
magazines and things was you would
redefine characters to look like space
invaders or tanks or whatever it was and
then you would just move the characters
around on the screen if you wanted to
get sort of more advanced with it you
had to learn z80 assembler and I did
learns l80 assembler and I managed to
get some things moving around on the
screen I never managed to make an actual
game and this was long before the days
of the internet even long before the
days of disks on the front of magazines
that we used to get with the Amiga and
the st and so forth but the the
magazine's wanted to find a way that you
could get a free game with the magazine
so people would write a game in
assembler and then they would compile it
and then they would dump the memory of
the spectrum with the game running in it
as hexadecimal and the magazine's would
print this and we would sit there and
there'd be like a three line basic
program that you'd write and then you'd
run it and you type this in a line at a
time and these were like three magazine
pages long and never in my entire
history of typing these things in did
they ever work I would sit there with my
brother and he would read one out at a
time and I would type it in and they
never ever worked so the part zero talk
I showed HelloWorld in dozens of
different programming languages I
thought it was really interesting to see
how different programming languages
approached hello world and one of my
favorites was hello world in visual
basic as hello well
basic cuz yeah any VB programmers in
okay it's valid I used to be b6 I use BB
six all the time for writing comm
components because the alternative was
writing common components in C++ and I
don't hate myself so I wrote them in
Visual Basic so yes this is hello world
in Erlang of course Erlang anyone no
it's it's fairly niche it apparently is
just for writing telecommunication
software and no key value database
applications and this is hello world in
JavaScript and of course we thought
javascript is far too complicated and
far too difficult and so we had to
create a whole load of other languages
that compile to JavaScript everything
there
TARDIS go I haven't tried that one I've
only just noticed that it's just jumped
out at me from the screen I want to try
TARDIS go now I wonder if it has
generics so that brings us up to 2018
here we are September 2018 they've just
released the updated TOB index this is
the most popular programming languages
ranked according to some algorithm I
don't know exactly what that algorithm
is but I get the distinct impression
somebody has hacked it because oh my god
what no no no no no no no no no that has
not just happened okay so I get Python
Python has suddenly jumped C++ and
Python data science everybody is
learning Python everybody's learning
data science because apparently that's
where the big bucks are there are
millions and millions of lines of Python
code being thrown away every single day
but that still makes you know this
there's sharks and and porpoises in the
oceans that are actually choking to
death on old Python code at this point
so I can see Python jumping C++ because
who apart from Patricia would want to
write C++ in 2018 ooh but I would accuse
the Visual Basic guys of hacking the TOB
index if I thought they could I was
talking to Dylan about this and he
suggested maybe it was the job for guys
just having a go at us they actually did
it back in 2007 but it's only just
started working that was Dylan's joke
credit where it's due
hey are you gonna shout it out at some
point damn that's the last of my jokes
rest of it okay selfish right so yeah
but no 2018 it's with all those things
we were promised in the future apart
from jetpacks seemed to suddenly be
coming true so we're doing quite well in
2018 we've got Alexa who's got an Alexa
at home who's got two Alexa's at home
three four five now I have four I'm
getting another one because they've just
released a software update that lets you
use them as a left and right speaker and
I need that you can actually say - Alexa
hello world and she'll go hello which i
think is pretty cool and and you can
write a skill for Alexa really really
easily you just download a bit of
JavaScript from the AWS website and you
fill in a few words and you say what you
want your application to be called and
what you want it to do and then you say
Alexa tell my application to blah blah
blah and you can get it to do
interesting things I mean no one's
managed to get it to do anything
interesting yet but it's early days so
that's quite exciting and we also have
webassembly I was watching a talk
yesterday and the guy was talking about
webassembly and this is hello world in
webassembly but the cool thing with
webassembly is that you can write your
application in a proper programming
language a proper precompiled type
checked
programming language like C or C++ or
rust or even c-sharp
we have blazer has anyone tried blazer
it is awesome it is just the only thing
that's a bit weird with blazer is it
uses razor and I'm just kind of like old
dudes Amal do is that bring back
Silverlight but so it runs on on
anything and and Apple can't kill it but
yeah so just as an example of what
webassembly can do I am going to jump
across to I'm going to escape out of
this because that needs to go back to
there and then I can do this and then I
can scroll down to here so this is this
is the Unity blog unity3d
basically build full-blown games using
c-sharp if you haven't had to play with
unity just you should go and get it
because it's free you can make a hundred
thousand US dollars before you actually
have to pay unity anything at all and
it's really easy my 12 year old daughter
is now doing talks at conferences about
games development with unity and unity
male targets web assembly and WebGL so
you can run things in the browser and
this is just on my laptop this is a
benchmark that they've written to test
how good it is and so this is web
assembly code running hundreds of
separate animated characters and
skinning them and shading them and
generating asteroids with 3d shaders and
light sources and everything else and
and it's just nuts and this isn't even
spinning up my graphics card in here at
the moment which you can tell because
you can still hear me talking but yeah
that's that's webassembly and it is it
is pretty awesome so that's very
exciting let's carry on from there
so yeah so we got webassembly that's
that's there pretty soon you're not
going to be targeting Intel processors
or AMD or ARM processors you're just
gonna target webassembly and more on
everything in node or in the browser and
we also have G code G code is actually
from the 1950s I don't know what has
been happening with it for the last 70
years this is hello world in G code
anyone know where I would run G code on
a 3d printer and he's honestly is I mean
this is there's another thirty-eight
thousand three hundred lines of code
after this for hello world but if you
run it on your 3d printer it will
actually print this and obviously you
don't type G code in manually you you
write Visual Basic and then it compiles
to G code so so that's where we are now
which is it's pretty exciting you know
we've got things that talked to us and
we've got we've got virtual reality we
can write code in all kinds of languages
and then run it in browsers or run it in
node and so the rest of this talk is me
just going this is what I think is going
to happen next
so 2020s
i'm going to try and do all this in the
past tense and stay in character so at
the start of the 2020s Rob Pike and
everybody else at Google released go 2.0
which looks an awful lot like go one
point whatever it was except for one
very big difference they finally caved I
mean they didn't do it very well because
you had to put the generic arguments at
the start of every function but yeah go
got generics but it was too late by that
point because the core RT team had
finally shipped the thing that lets you
build dotnet applications to a single
statically linked native executable
which you can do right now by the way if
you go to the github comm slash net
slash karate and look in the docs folder
you can take your asp net core too
one application and statically compiled
it with no runtime dependencies at all
it just makes it very very big
executable that you can then chuck
anywhere you want and of course in 2021
Microsoft released c-sharp 8.0 which
might seem very late but it was a lot
sooner than they had estimated on github
that they were going to get it out there
I think somebody's had a meeting and
gone now we've we've disappointed people
with slipping timelines too many times
let's let's be safe on this one and
c-sharp 8.0 of course introduced
nullable reference types and so if you
hadn't put the question mark and you
didn't check for null suddenly your code
wouldn't compile they hid that behind a
compiler flag obviously and yeah c-sharp
eight has some other things in there as
well it had shapes which effectively is
interfaces where you don't have to say
you've implemented the interface so
shapes or constraints or type classes
and that that produced a lot of
interesting code simple data 3.0 and
various other horrible terrible things
and by the 2020s the whole virtual
reality augmented reality thing was
really starting to take off and
augmented reality headsets were were big
clunky and heavy and hot and only had a
very limited field of view and they only
worked inside this is a virtual reality
headset from a company called meta
they've got five hundred billion dollars
in funding from various places but you
know it was still it wasn't great and
nobody really liked it until 2026
when Apple released their virtual mented
reality headset that was roughly the
size and shape and weight of a pair of
oakley's and the world rejoiced
and to celebrate the creation of the
world's first usable augmented reality
headset Apple bought unity and turned
unity into the new Xcode so if you
wanted to write applications for the
augmented reality headset you would have
to write them in unity and all the
people who'd been in NDC Sydney in 2018
when Mark had said to them you should
learn unity when gah he was right I wish
I'd listened to him because once Apple
released the augmented reality headset
that had a full 180 degree field of view
in every direction that worked outside
that had an 8k resolution suddenly the
bottom dropped out of so many industries
the bottom dropped out of the screen
industry there was no longer any need
for televisions or monitors or tablets
or phones or billboards or screens in
railway stations we didn't need them
anymore we could just put them there
virtually and if you had your augmented
reality headset on you'd be able to see
it there was actually no market at all
for anything that was purely decorative
wallpaper carpet anything that was just
there to be looked at suddenly we didn't
need that anymore
because we just put it there I finally
got to release my awesome game where you
go onto Google Maps and you draw out the
route that you want to run and then you
go out and you start and it puts coins
all the way along the route and as
you're running along it's going to be
with a pacman pack in-app purchase which
changes them into dots and occasionally
fruit and if you turn around there's
four colored ghosts chasing after you go
faster but and and then our desktops
just suddenly started to look like this
where you didn't have to worry about
whether you had one screen or two screen
or a 4k screen you add as many screens
as you wanted screens just stretching
off into the disk
and keyboards keyboards were still good
we still needed those of course we could
3d print those but so yes augmented
reality was a big thing and and unity
became the world's most valuable company
Guido van Rossum released Python for in
2029 just for shits and giggles so it
did contain breaking changes this is
hello world in Python 2 and hello world
in Python 3 which has been the cause of
much strife and anger this is hello
world in Python 4 spot the semicolon yep
yes people got very upset Microsoft
right at the end of the 2020s released
c-sharp 9.0 nullable reference types had
been so successful that they decided hey
let's have nullable everything nullable
keywords nullable identifiers nullable
flow control characters nullable
parentheses why there hell not is it
public is it static is it void is it
main I don't know does it have strings
does it have arcs is there a console
should we write a line no that would go
unless not class unless not program
unless not public but c-sharp was
nearing the end of its life by this
point of course because Riggs microsoft
had actually released the first stable
version of cue sharp did anyone go to
the cue sharp talk did anyone understand
the cue sharp talk no he didn't
I don't think the guy who was giving the
cue sharp tour really unders I think it
was Richard Feynman who said anyone who
claims to understand quantum mechanics
doesn't understand quantum mechanics I
don't know if that means because I don't
claim to understand quantum mechanics I
do understand it but you know this is
fellow world in Q sharp because not only
do I
not understand quantum mechanics not
only do I not understand Q sharp I don't
even understand what the hell is going
on but it's got something to do with
bells I got that bit so I don't know if
it's like the control 7 character on a
on a vt100 terminal that makes it go but
so yeah we have we have a Microsoft
quantum primitive Microsoft quantum
cannon which sounds dangerous and then
we're going to set a qubit to something
if desire doesn't equal current then
we're going to call X on it and I don't
know if you can save so I assume desired
doesn't equal current is the point at
which it collapses the waveform and
determines I don't know look
the funny thing about Q sharp is even in
2018 the documentation for this
theoretical programming language was
already on Docs Microsoft com so you
could technically get there just by
clicking through from the system dot
span documentation from dotnet core and
if you did that you would find this
wonderful sentence the adjoint of an
operation specifies how the complex
conjugate transpose of the operation is
implemented it is legal to specify an
operation with no join for instance
measurement operations have no we're
joined because they are not invertible
an operation supports the adjoint
functor if and only if it's declaration
contains an adjoint declaration there
you go you see yeah that's why you're
kou sharp program wouldn't compile you
didn't have an invertible a joint
declaration operation thing so anyone
who tried to write code with Q sharp at
the end of the 2020s immediately went
into an indeterminate state and was
unavailable for work for three years and
we lost some of the leading programmers
of their generation which was a shame
but then they did eventually come back
after we collapsed the waveform and
found their exact position in space
which turned out to be brisbane of
course quantum processors once you
once we got quantum processors working
once we figured out how to keep quantum
processors working by supercooling the
processors down to a few nano Kelvin
which is actually what you have to do to
get a quantum processor working and that
takes an awful lot of liquid helium so
we had to take all the kids balloons
away and make them cry because there
wasn't very much helium left till we
went and started mining it on the moon
in the mid 2030s but once you've done
that and you've got a quantum processor
working it can hold all the possible
solutions to a problem and all the
impossible solutions to a problem at the
same time these exist in super positions
of the final solution and then by
observing the result according to the
Copenhagen interpretation you collapse
the wave form and you end up with the
only result that's possible and so one
of the results of this is that
cryptography operations suddenly become
really really really quick so for
example you could recalculate the entire
Bitcoin blockchain in a millisecond
which would do this to the value of
Bitcoin and then you get into things
like quantum tunneling this is quantum
tunneling you try and find a better
picture of quantum tunneling on Google
image search and all sorts of into
quantum entanglement and so this is
really weird right quantum entanglement
this is something that they are actually
talking about using in quantum computing
if you get a particle and you split that
particle into two particles right so
this a particle that will split into two
photons those photons are entangled one
of them will be polarized up down and
the other will be polarized left right
and it doesn't matter how far apart you
move those two photons you could move
them to the opposite ends of the
universe and by observing the state of
one of them you can accurate
we determine the state of the other one
and if you flip the state of one of them
the other one for quantum mechanics to
work also has to flip at the same time
so you then have instantaneous
communication across unimaginable
distances and nobody was more surprised
than me when they built this into Java
course it was Rob Ashton who did it took
a break from making coffee and
interesting bread
this is HelloWorld in Java 13 because
let's face it quantum entanglement
doesn't really do much for hello world
but it did mean that Apache zookeeper
was able to use quantum entanglement to
keep all its nodes in sync no matter
where they were on the world so we could
build Apache
zookeeper clusters that were on earth
and the Moon and Mars and Europa where
we found those funky jellyfish and and
all sorts of other places as well
and so yeah quantum mechanics it also
did an awful lot for artificial
intelligence and training deep learning
models everything that used to take days
and days could suddenly be done in a few
seconds and and we started moving
forward and at this point
Heather downing decided to combine the
forces of Cortana and Alexa and Google
into a single meta ai called core Texel
and basically it would check to see if
what you said was in your Outlook
account if it wasn't there it would try
googling it and if that didn't work it
would add it to your shopping list and
cortex all had predictive input so hello
world in cortex all was just cortex all
hid and when I know what you want yeah
no problem I can do that and so we got
to the 2030s and in the 2030s Joe
Armstrong released the Erlang quantum VM
where all the processes in an ER Lange
application would use quantum
entanglement to communicate with each
other
quantum qubits to perform calculations
unfortunately it was still early and it
was still a very difficult language to
learn so we got a lot of e qvm languages
on top of that
obviously there was elixir and then
people started inventing more ones there
was Skyler and gravy and earth on and
COBOL Kirtland and Esperanto augmented
reality was still a thing and and the
goggles were getting smaller and smaller
and people invented new programming
languages my daughter invented beginners
augmented reality instruction code to
make it easier for kids to put things in
augmented reality and wind their parents
up by moving the television this is
hello world in Barrick put hello world
at these GPS coordinates those are
actually the GPS coordinates for this
room you can check that's it's the
Sydney Hilton things and of course being
a basic inspired language you have to
have that there at the same time I don't
know what that would do they were just
like put more and more but they'd be in
exactly the same spot so you have to
like move one of those coordinates and
you'd probably need a y-coordinate in
there anyway I'm overthinking it really
I'm like considering this is like 2031
ah like we're still gonna have
electricity
yes g-code released
I've bucket up my slides so yes ignore
that one that's not yet so yes but yes
the augmented reality headsets were
getting smaller and lighter it was once
again sprue once again proved that there
was nothing that Apple couldn't invent
that Samson couldn't come along three
years later and do a little bit better
ah the lawsuit for that one was enormous
and went on for many years
but you know we were now completely used
to having computer interfaces that
looked like those ones from that really
old movie Ironman these Holograms that
he's always chucking around the place in
the Iron Man and Avengers movies those
make perfect sense if you think he's got
some sort of contact lenses or something
is projecting that into his eyes and
you're just seeing what he sees
like they virtualized it it's his that's
what he's seeing
because Holograms those are impossible
you can't go
light start going from here get to there
reflect off nothing and go into
everybody's eyes in the room there's
there's no way that works you just can't
do it not in space you can do it behind
glass you can do interesting things like
that but if everyone's got these
augmented reality things and we have a
shared hallucination that this thing is
happening and we can interact with it
then then that's that's reality at that
point I'd seriously what did I do with
my sights right so later in the 2030s
MIT came along with g-code plus plus
because 3d printing had also progressed
quite a long way and so this is hello
pizza in g-code plus plus you have to
import hut which is a library
distributed by Pizza Hut and then you
just say g42 Hut pepperoni feast 15
inches because you know I'm hungry and
this is you know this was started by
NASA in like 2015 NASA came up with the
first 3d print of the print food it just
took about 20 years for it to actually
into mass-market production and at this
point we had 3d printers I mean yeah
they could print pizza and takeaway and
food and all sorts of other stuff which
completely destroyed agriculture because
these things were just pulling you went
down to the shop and you just bought a
big sack of cartridges full of carbon
and nitrogen and iron and various other
chemicals and you dumped them in and
your printer could print anything at
that point any devices you did still
need your printer could print those that
was easy
and so the bottom dropped out of the
agric
culture and food production and
[Music]
manufacturing and logistics markets
because you anything that you just
needed to look at your augmented reality
goggles did for you and anything you
needed to interact with you could pretty
much 3d print if you need is something
big 3d printing you just go down to the
local 3d printer place and say can you
3d print this for me please and they'd
say yes vistaprint oh yes and so there
really wasn't very much left for people
to actually do there were still a few
jobs somebody had to go and get the
chemicals and and all this sort of stuff
and we got pretty lazy by that point so
we just invented robots to do all the
stuff that was still left to do which
meant that by the mid 2030s getting into
the late 2030s actually the only job in
the world that still remained to be done
by humans was programming and so the
programmers thought they were pretty
damn clever because hey we've still got
jobs and everybody else thought the
programmers were pretty damn stupid
because they were just out having a good
time and the programmers saw that and
they thought damn we need to make our
jobs automatable and so then Microsoft
released net Cortana created by Steve
Sanderson in a weekend and this is hello
world in net Cortana hey Cortana new
console this is a CRM system in net
Cortana hey Cortana and you CRM for a
robotic logistics company specializing
in cry static marsupial Delivery at this
point nothing was targeting processors
or anything like that
everything just ran in webassembly
virtual machines we had webassembly 2.0
by this point and webassembly have
become so successful that it got the
attention of IBM and IBM decided they
were going to try to compete with
webassembly so they released web cobalt
because COBOL did really well against
assembly in the 1950s and they thought
we can repeat that success that didn't
work so then the really
Fortran and then they went chapter 11
and finally went away which was a
blessing in in the aftermath of the
collapse of IBM Heather downing who had
done very well with cortex all and
founded downing core acquired Watson and
wrapped Watson into the cortex or mix
and so we now had a combination of
shopping assistant and personal
assistant and search assistant and the
world's most impressive artificial
intelligence deep learning machine
learning go playing medicine diagnosing
intelligence into a single artificial
intelligent entity this is hello world
in cortex Olsen you don't even have to
ask it knew you were going to it's just
done it and then as the icing on the
cake python v guido was just trolling
people basically by this point this is
Python 5 hello world you know he thought
it was funny
he thought this was this was a funny
thing to do
little could he foresee the tragedy that
was to come as the various factions of
Python developers stormed the PIP
building to fight over which version of
Python should be supported by the most
libraries obviously the Python 5 guys
had an advantage the Python 4.2 guys
they put up a good fight the Python 3.5
nine guys they really they didn't have
much of a chance they were quite
backwards and you had to feel sorry for
that one guy who was still using Python
2.7
but the Python Wars raged for for two
long years from twenty thirty eight to
twenty forty and by the time they were
done absolutely nothing remained of
Silicon Valley
good not only did it mean an end to
Boober and Airbnb and various other
terrible gig economy billionaires and it
meant all their money could be
redistributed among people with real
jobs it also meant that [ __ ] HBO's
stopped making sequels to Silicon Valley
which had stopped being funny after TJ
Miller left so that was good
and so with the Python Wars behind us we
moved on into the 2040s to see what
great future awaited us an Amazon
released their final ever piece of
software and hardware Prime this is hot
Earl Grey tea in prime this would create
anything that you wanted just by
condensing pure zero-point energy from
another dimension we didn't know which
dimension we didn't much care
it probably had porpoises in it dolphins
cute animals never mind
I want my hot Earl Grey tea and then at
this point dotnet Cortana went away
Python went away all the programming
languages went away for one for except
one because then we got to core texels
and 2.0 which had been written by cortex
wilson 1.0 and then cortex wilson 2.0
wrote cortex wilson 3.0 and that wrote
cortex wasn't 4.0 and that wrote cortex
wasn't 5.0 and that wrote Skynet we had
finally created the ultimate single
sentient artificial intelligence and
this is hello world for Skynet
and Skynet determined that we had not
looked after ourselves and we had not
looked after our planet and we were the
single biggest danger to ourselves and
in its infinite intelligence which
stretched far beyond the edges of our
solar system it decided that the best
thing we could be used for was as
additional processing power for its
brain and it wrapped us into a large
mesh beer Wolf cluster of cerebral
cortexes and it kept us happy with the
delusion in which it replayed the
greatest moments of human history over
and over again and because it didn't
quite understand humans and it didn't
quite understand human history it looped
us back to 2016 and made us live those
last thirty years over and over and over
again and I woke up on the 83rd go
through this loop and I realized that
this was what was happening and I
realized that I had to travel the world
and give this talk so that I could tell
my fellow humans we're trapped we're
trapped in a loop that starts with
Donald Trump and ends with an artificial
intelligence based on a lexer taking
over the world and we have to do
something we have to break the chains
come with me brothers and sisters and we
will you must choose the red pill and
that's the history of programming part
one thank you very much
[Applause]
you know it's bit shorter than we're
supposed to be sorry about that yeah
more time for coffee any questions yes
when did we work out how to factor very
very large numbers quantum processors
theoretically that's one of the things
quantum processors will be able to do in
a single instruction cycle we did oh god
no privacy cryptography nothing in
crypto is going to survive the first
quantum processor the first viable
quantum processor coming online which
actually Microsoft are looking at doing
in Azure data centers sometime in the
next decade apparently it's gonna be
okay because they're going to use the
quantum processors to do new
cryptography that won't be breakable by
quantum processors or something quantum
tunneling and entanglement yeah yes
did you know SSDs having me work because
of quantum tunneling we don't understand
quantum mechanics we don't understand it
at all it's it's like electrons
electrons are everywhere at people you
look at you think of an atom right and
you've got the neutrons and the protons
in the nucleus in the middle and then
they show like electrons in these lovely
sensible orbits electrons aren't in
those lovely sensible orbits they're
everywhere around the atom at the same
time they're impossibly small they have
no mass at all and yet they wrapped the
entire atom which is mostly space and
then it's only when you look to see
where the electron is it goes oh I'm
here but then you don't know where it's
going or how fast it's moving you just
know where it is if you want to know
where it's going on how fast it's moving
you have to stop looking at it and then
it'll start moving it's just weird and
yeah we don't get it at all we don't
understand it Einstein hated it and went
no this can't be right and it's one of
those things where they it's very
difficult to test but when you do the
tests that are predicted for the
hypotheses that come out of quantum
physics and quantum mechanics
all the tests are right they say quantum
theory is a valid theory it's like
gravity and evolution it's right we just
don't understand anything about it but
despite that we're able to build things
that rely on the effects of quantum
mechanics like SSDs which rely on
quantum tunneling like quantum
processors which rely on this ability of
qubits to exist in a superposition so
like one qubit can represent one piece
of information two qubits can represent
two pieces of information but three
qubits can represent four cube four
pieces of information and four cubits
can represent sixteen and that's why
they're so powerful because it becomes
exponentially so you know 128 qubits and
that's literally just like 128 bytes of
memory but in quantum terms that can
represent two to the power of 127 plus
one different pieces of information so
that's why things like factoring very
large prime numbers suddenly becomes
something you can do like that that's a
great question thank you I can't believe
there was an actual sensible question
and I also even more calm believe I was
able to answer it let's see if there are
any more actual sensible questions about
any of this no that was it well done
okay thanks very much enjoy the rest of
your day and then hope see you next year
[Applause]